c'est l'heure de notre débat décalé plus
prospectif avec un rendez-vous vous
allez retrouver régulièrement pendant
cette campagne présidentielle on passe
au crible une promesse électorale et on
se demande si c'est une idée neuve ou
une idée courte
idée neuve où il écourte on passe donc
au crible la proposition d'un ou
plusieurs candidats aujourd'hui c'est la
nationalisation des autoroutes promise
par marine le pen arnaud montebourg et
quand ils étaient encore en course et le
vert eric piolle pourquoi l'idée les
séduit réponse avec flora sauvage
parmi les candidats à la présidentielle
ils sont nombreux de jean-luc mélenchon
à sandrine rousseau en passant par
marine le pen a prôné le rachat des
concessions d'autoroutes selon la
présidente du rassemblement national
cette mesure permettrait de faire
baisser de 10 à 15 % le prix des péages
et de livrer un milliard et demi d'euros
supplémentaires par an au budget de
l'état pour la liberté de circuler c'est
évidemment celle de le faire à un prix
raisonnable
ainsi la nationalisation des autoroutes
permettra de stopper l'inflation des
prix des péages cédé en 2006 par l'état
des entreprises privées les concessions
autoroutières doivent arriver à échéance
à partir de 2031
pour arnaud montebourg la privatisation
s'est faite au détriment de l'état la
nationalisation des autoroutes
rapportera 3 milliards à l'état pour moi
ça doit financer l'écologisation des
moyens de transport mais d'interrompre
les contrats de concession avant leur
échéance implique le versement d'une
indemnité de compensation selon le
gouvernement l'état devrait débourser 47
milliards d'euros pour récupérer le
réseau autoroutier ont expertisé le
montant de la rente et il faut se
référer aux principes qui ont été
définis par le conseil d'état il compose
pour calculer l'indemnité d'une barre le
patrimoine
mais l'état ne dispose pas de
l'inventaire de ce patrimoine que
constituent les autoroutes ce qui rend
impossible le chiffrage de l'indemnité
de rupture et attendre la fin des
concessions ne dispense pas l'état de
s'acquitter d'une indemnité au titre du
patrimoine contrairement à ce que laisse
entendre l'exécutif
la nationalisation des autoroutes on en
débat tout de suite avec mes invités
hervé maurey bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes sénateur centriste de l'eure
ancien président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable au sénat
j'accueille également paul cassia
bonsoir bonsoir professeur de droit
public à l'université paris 1 panthéon
sorbonne
olivier babeau bonsoir bonsoir
économistes fondateur de l'institut
sapiens hauteur en 2020 d'une étude sur
les concessions autoroutières alors
c'est une rubrique idées neuves idées
courtes qu'on a lancé la semaine
dernière c'était anne hidalgo avec le
doublement des salaires des les profs et
même des personnels au contact des des
enfants dans l'éducation nationale donc
la nationaliser les autoroutes je
commence à chaque fois par poser tout
simplement la question idées neuves ou
et des cours qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais moi c'est pas une idée neuve
puisque c'est quelque chose qui revient
assez régulièrement qui a déjà eu les
travaux à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat ya pas loin d'une dizaine d'années
sur le sujet donc si on reste sur une
réponse bref c'est une idée neuve hockey
est ce que c'est une idée courte c'est
une idée oui un petit peu courte sera
l'occasion d'en reparler dont évidemment
la rentrée après je continue autour de
tables paul cassia moi je rejoins ce qui
vient d'être dit par un seul sénateur
effectivement il ya déjà eu des
propositions de loi qui ont été déposées
devant les deux chambres elles n'ont pas
abouti pour autant c'est une idée courte
alors c'est une idée courte
c'est une idée c'est une bonne idée je
crois a donc vous vous y êtes
olivier babeau c'est une idée courte si
on ne prend pas en compte le fait que
les choses sont beaucoup plus
compliquées qu'elles ne semblait quand
il ne les explique et donc c'est en tout
cas une très bonne occasion de faire de
la pédagogie d'un modèle économique qui
est pas très bien connu en réalité la
barre c'est ce qu'on va faire on va
faire un peu de de pédagogie il ya un an
je vais appeler le jonathan du prix yes
je sais pas s'il est déjà là jonathan
mais sinon il va il va arriver parce que
monsieur le sénateur il ya un an vous
aviez remis un volumineux rapport
commission d' enquête sur le contrôle la
régulation et l'évolution des
concessions autoroutières jonathan du
prix s genou le résumé ce rapport mais
avec plaisir à thomas mais vous voyez
arriver à 100 pages je vais vous le
faire sur notre les sénateurs ont
décortiqué huit mois durant les quinze
ans de privatisation des autoroutes et
les constats dressés il faut bien le
dire ils sont assez édifiants le premier
d'entre eux selon les sénateurs est bien
c'est que les autoroutes elles ont été
cédées au privé pour 14 8 milliards
d'euros en 2006 à les voir ce chiffre
s'afficher derrière moi c'est un montant
jugé pour le moins avantageux par les
parlementaires qui certes à l'époque a
permis de renflouer un peu les caisses
de l'état à court terme mais qui selon
certaines projections des sénateurs
auraient engendré en fait dans le même
temps 6 5 à 7 8 milliards d'euros de
pertes de recettes pour nos finances
publiques
là j'ai une relance
les sénateurs qui ont révélé que les
sociétés autoroutières allait engranger
des profits astronomiques dans les
prochaines années exactement 1 2 des 3
sociétés autoroutières qui gère le
réseau en france eiffage et vinci pour
ne pas les nommer atteindront dès 2022
la rentabilité qu'ils espéraient
normalement dix ans plus tard le rapport
sénatorial donné à donner d'ailleurs
cette projection elle aussi assez
édifiante des dividendes prévisionnel de
vinci regarder sur la période 2020 2030
si ce qui pourrait s'élever à 20 7
milliards d'euros ces chiffres
vertigineux en tous les cas pose
question notamment aux centristes
vincent de l'est qui était l'un des
co-auteurs du rapport écouter pour deux
groupes
ils auront atteint la rentabilité
attendue délits dès le début du contrat
ces derniers pour cent ce qui est quand
même une bonne rentabilité plus de dix
ans avant la fin des contrats sa vie
repenser les dix dernières années du
contrat en fait il y ait de l'argent
alors qu'ils ont déjà engrangé la
rentabilité attendue au départ voilà ce
qu'on peut appeler les surprofits ni les
surprofits le terme employé que propose
le sénat qu'a proposé le sénat alors le
sénat a notamment je vais pas vous faire
toutes les mesures mais il a notamment
plaidé pour une limitation à 15 ans de
la durée de ces concessions en y
incluant notamment des clauses de
revoyure c'est la priorité des priorités
afin de redéfinir je cite un mot du
rapport redéfinir les équilibres
économiques et financiers des contrats
qui sont en fait des contrats
globalement très mal ficelé au détriment
de l'état et donc des usagers mais c'est
évidemment extrêmement complexe un déjà
parce que certains de ces contrats comme
celui notamment de 2015 ont été noués en
toute opacité un cet accord il prévoyait
en échange de travaux de plus de 3
milliards d'euros engagés par les
sociétés autoroutières un allongement de
la durée des concessions autoroutes et
autoroutières assorti d'une hausse des
péages et d'autant que pour remettre les
choses à plat il faudrait aussi que les
sociétés autoroutières coopèrent ce qui
n'est pas vraiment le cas on se souvient
hervé maurey face au pdg de vinci
autoroutes vous étiez heurté un mur on
peut le dire en demandant des
informations sur ce fameux protocole de
2015 regardez ce que ça fait deux ans
qu'il est disponible sur le site de
mediapart et donc il est très facile de
le consulter en tout cas pour ce qui
nous concerne nous n'avons pas de
difficulté en parler je suis pas certain
que votre dernière remarque si je peux
me permettre soit très pertinente parce
que me répondre vous n'avez pas pu
obtenir vous commission compétente du
sénat la communication d'un protocole
mais vous aviez calé sur le site de
médiapart honnêtement monsieur je trouve
que ça n'est pas correct voilà cet
échange assez tendu
en tout cas pour les sénateurs il faut
rapidement se mettre autour de la table
pour renégocier ces contrats avant que
la situation n'atteigne peut-être un
point de non retour merci jonathan pour
cette cette rubrique cette chronique
assez exhaustive hervé maurey c'était
tendu quand même cet échange devrait
revenir là dessus parce qu' est-ce que
c'est pas finalement révélateur de
l'état d'esprit des patrons des
concessions autoroutières aux russes
tout pas nous arriver grand chose quoi
je crois qu'effectivement cet échange je
suis ravi de le revoir je trouve que
c'est très bien qu'on comptait présenter
ce soir est assez révélateur d'un
sentiment de toute puissance pour pas
dire de domination de ses grand groupe
en l'occurrence vinci qui considèrent
qu'ils n'ont de rondes de compte à
rendre à personne et surtout pas au
parlement on voit qu'ils ont des des
contrats de concession
qu'il ordonne une très large latitude
pour une très longue durée avec une des
mauvaises habitudes auxquelles il faut
absolument mettre fin c'est à dire le
fait qu'on l'ait prolonge régulièrement
donc on à l'éternité on fait ce qu'on
veut on rendre compte à personne et sous
le passé l'expression à un peu triviale
on s'en met plein les poches au passage
et ça je trouve que c'est pas acceptable
je trouve que l'extrait vous avez passé
montre bien la position de ces groupes
qui effectivement des profits que le
socom comme ça a été rappelé je parlais
de vinci à l'instant je rappellerai
juste que l'activité autoroutière
représente 13 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires et 60% leurs bénéfices donc
je crois que ce seul chiffre il résume
la situation donc moi je suis pas
hostile aux concessions je suis pas va
dire il faut nationaliser je
m'expliquerai pourquoi si vous le
souhaitez mais je pense qu'il faut
arriver comme ça a été rappelée à des
situations beaucoup plus équilibrée et
et que ce ne soit pas l'état la nation
les français qui en fait soit totalement
en un sentiment d'infériorité vis-à-vis
de ces groupes là et donc le droit que
c'est vers cela qu'il faut tendre
olivier vaudou leur action peut être à
la séquence qu'on a vu de cette
commission denquête et puis est-ce que
ce que dit le sénateur maurey à
l'instant c'est à ce sentiment un peu
peut-être de toute puissance des
concessions autoroutières est ce
qu'elles sont contrôlés finalement et si
oui comment alors le prix des
concessions enfin le prix le tarif des
péages il n'est pas libre il fait
l'objet d'un encadrement qui est
extrêmement stricte et d'évolution
effectivement qui sont liées à chaque
fois qu'il ya un allongement de la
concession à des travaux qui sont
demandés par ailleurs par l'état
bombasse après c'est une négociation en
effet c'est à la fin du contrat qu'il va
falloir peut-être bar poser les choses
renégocier un contrat de façon peut-être
plus intelligente plus plus clairvoyante
et en calculant différemment sur le
moment dont il était bien content de
toucher les 15000 parce que jusque là on
tg mills ont touché 300 millions par an
de dividendes en fait un aujourd'hui
donc on a eu une année 15 milliards et
aujourd'hui il faut dire que sur le prix
du péage 40% de ce prix il va à l'état à
travers les impôts donc il faut quand
même toujours signalé que quand les gens
trouvent que les péages c'est cher il ya
40% qui va qui va à l'état mais c'est
très important
c'était 2005 c'est sa manière le prix 15
milliards différentes côté pour sonder
la crise de la dette ont attisé pour
désendetter on était assez content
évidemment accorde 15 milliards dhs pour
un état impécunieux c'est toujours
formidable mais il faut il faut toujours
peut-être signaler que pour les gens il
ya cette idée que quand vous avez un
tarif que vous voyez c'est beaucoup plus
douloureux que quand c'est pris en
charge par le contribuable autant il ya
que deux modèles vous avez un service
public d'une façon ou d'une autre c'est
soit le contribuable soit l'usagé
l'usagé c'est pas mal de le faire payer
surtout quand vous avez beaucoup de
camions étrangers qui passent par les
autoroutes et qui vont payer les péages
donc c'est un modèle qui que ce soit un
concessionnaire public ou privé est en
fait assez vertueux donc l'idée que
demain on va pouvoir baisser les prix
considérablement parce que ça sera un
opérateur public c'est pas tout à fait
certain parce qu'il ya en plus des
normes d'énormes investissements à faire
on parle de nationalisation les appels
et les acteurs privés sont peut-être
plus efficace que l'acteur public pose
c'est une question est ce que est ce que
le lecteur publiée car ça aussi bien
d'ailleurs il ya aujourd'hui des
concessionnaires public c'est existants
il y en a deux à ma connaissance encore
son examen public mais d'ailleurs quand
on parle de nationalisation c'est
marrant parce qu'en fait c'est
nationaliser les autoroutes elles sont
elles appartiennent et lycées elles
seront rendues et consomme 1 voilà sont
les concessions elles sont rendues craie
en main et il faut souligner que c'est
un modèle qui existe depuis louis xiv
qui l'a utilisé pour le canal du midi et
que ça permet de développer ça on
l'utilisé pour le rail beaucoup ça
permet de développer des des réseaux
d'utilité publique sans que sans bourse
délier pour la collectivité puisque le
risque est assumé par le privé et
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être là qu'il faut
il faut terminer on parle de rente de
rendre peut-être après coup enfin sur le
moment la rente c'est surtout assumer le
risque le risque de retard le risque
d'augmentation du prix des travaux et
donc peut-être que le surprofits comme
on l'appelle il est aussi lié à cette
capacité à avoir mené à bien ses travaux
mais je dis pas qu'il faut pas à
renégocier une fois qu'on arrive à la
fin du contrat et puis faire
ce débat comme on l'a aujourd'hui de
dire parce qu'on a tous envie de
reprendre en main les autoroutes et on
dit qu'on fera mieux que les autres
alors pourquoi cette idée elle séduit
certains candidats je vais d'abord vous
proposez tient de d'écouter le ministre
en charge du secteur me lisez transports
jean baptiste djebbari qui réagissait à
cette proposition de candidats de de
l'opposition pour lui c'est clairement
une idée courte écoutez c'est une
proposition bien populiste et bien
démagogique parce que d'abord les
concessions autoroutières elles ont été
contractualisés par l'état à des
conditions qui ont d'ailleurs plusieurs
foyers et revu elle arrive à échéance en
2031 dans le disent entre messi ont
nationalisé maintenant on devrait payer
on devrait parler droit des contrats par
l'état doit on devrait indemniser les
sociétés d'autoroute à hauteur de 45 à
50 milliards sur le fond moi je demande
à voir concrètement dr y compris arnaud
montebourg n'a pas été très clair sur le
comment on fait je demande à voir ce
qu'ils proposent concrètement une fois
qu'ils ont dépensé 50 milliards
populiste et démagogue à ce que disait
jean baptisé djebbari laetitia pourquoi
les séduit des candidats finalement
aussi des différents rappels marine le
pen à arnaud montebourg et ses troupes
s'étaient encore qu'on est d'ailleurs il
pioche ouais c'est trans partisan fabien
roussel theory voyez ça va sur tout
l'échiquier politique pourquoi j'avance
une piste de réflexion c'était une des
principales revendications des gilet
jaune il y à une france qui se paupérise
que tous les politiques constate et donc
on va répondre directement aux français
et on leur répond via le porte monnaie
et puisque c'est une mesure qui va être
efficace immédiatement en tout cas ce
qu'il apporte fond cette promesse là
c'est à dire monsieur vous le dit qu' on
ne sait pas encore de combien on pourra
économiser sur un péage mais eux nous
pouvons la promesse que ce sera moins
chère de toute façon est finalement une
enfin côté de ça il aura fallu sortir je
ne sais combien de milliards anoh
montebourg c'est quand on écoute arnaud
montebourg il ya on va aller devant les
tribunaux ont pas gagné ça va nous
coûter 300 millions euros de frais
d'avocat c'est le sait le verbatim
d'arnaud montebourg ce n'est pas le mien
simplement je pense que gilles de robien
s'ils ont juste on prend un tout petit
peu de champ et on sort de la course à
l'échalote présidentielle c'est gilles
de robien justement devant la commission
bancaire du sénat en 2020 qui avait eu
cette phrase il me semble assez
symptomatique de la situation il avait
dit on ne privatise jamais un monopole
et quand on privatise cela devient une
rente de situation et je crois que c'est
cela monsieur qui pose problème à tout
le monde ce n'est pas des 40% qui vont à
l'état c'est les 20 pour cent de
bénéfice net qui ne sont pas réinvestis
on ne sait pas où ils vont aux
actionnaires dans la poche de qui est
donc cette vache à lait permanente à
laquelle les français participent on
comprend qu'il y ait un ras-le-bol donc
on comprend que ça devienne une mesure
dans une course présidence alors pour le
cas ci a effectivement cessé la
rentabilité en fait qui est au coeur du
beaucoup de choses à dire le contrat de
concession c'est effectivement un
procédé très anciens c'est un procédé
par lequel une personne publique une
administration ici l'état confie à un
tiers une personne privée des sociétés
privées le soin de gérer un service
public ici les autoroutes ça ça se fait
tous les jours partout dans toutes les
communes bon le la particularité d'un
contrat de concession c'est que le
concessionnaire c'est à dire celui
acquis et transféré le soin d'exécuter
le service public doit connaître un
risque financier dans l'exécution de la
concession il n'y a pas de concession
sans risque financier or ici ce qui se
passe c'est qu'il est acquis par
pratiquement tout le monde que les
concessions autoroutières ne comporte
aucun risque et n'ont jamais comporté le
moindre risque pour les sociétés
concessionnaires on vient d'évoquer le
seuil de 8% de rentabilité annuelle ça
n'existe nulle part ailleurs que pour
les sociétés concessionnaires donc ceux
qui posent difficulté c'est pas le
principe de la concession c'est la
rentabilité excessive qui est octroyée
aux sociétés concessionnaires et c'est
ce point là qui doit absolument être été
avant la fin des contrats de concession
avant 2030 et en 2036 un mot de réponse
là-dessus olivier babeau parce que j'ai
pas si vous êtes d'accord sur la
rentabilité excessive qu'est ce que moi
je n'ai pas d'avis tranché je sais que
c'est très compliqué d'autant plus que
en élite et vous savez comme on dit à la
campagne ça la fin du marché qu'on
compte il faut compter les bouses et
donc c'est à la fin de la concession
qu'il faut regarder l'ensemble des
investissements et puis l'ensemble des
rentabilités on n'y est pas encore tout
à fait
on est au point après il ya d'autres
investissements il est investissement
important de modernisation des
autoroutes qui sont qui sont assumés
après effectivement et ce qu'on a mal
fixé de prix ce qu'on est mal fixé son
évolution est-ce que ça a été mon
problème en mal vu parce que c'est très
difficile d'anticiper aussi des
évolutions de besoins de trafic
qui font que bomba aujourd'hui le la
rentabilité est très très forte mais est
ce que j'observe c'est que le prix il
est quand même pas du tout libre de la
part des des concessions autoroutières
donc comment n'attend pas le moyen
d'encadrer et d'accompagner cette
progression pour qu'elle soit faite à la
satisfaction en effet d'un grand public
qui a l'impression que c'est devenu
extrêmement cher à tort ou à raison tout
cas ça va évidemment être la question
hervé maurey sur les prix il ya bien
sûr les prix c'est nous et agen c'est
simplement parce que l'état n'a pas été
bons dans les négociations et je pense
que ça tient aussi à l'affaiblissement
de de la qualité des compétences dont
l'état dispose en interne moi j'ai eu
l'occasion dans des travaux la
commission de devoir les escouades de
conseillers de haut niveau de ces
entreprises qui malheureusement pour
l'état sont devenus très souvent d'un
niveau très supérieur à ceux qui gèrent
le contrat à bercy dont je ne sais
quelle administration indépendante du
mystère de la route c'est peut-être
assez brutale que steam mais ça
correspond à l'arrivée alors moi je suis
pas du tout contre ni les concessions je
suis contre les concessions qui
conduisent à des surprofits comme vous
l'avez dit je suis pas contre le fait
que l'usagé paye mais je suis contre le
fait que l'usagé payent trop cher n'est
trop cher par rapport à quoi par rapport
à ce qui doit être le la rémunération
normale du concessionnaire d'autant plus
que voulait l'appeler monsieur il n'y a
absolument aucun risque vous évoquiez
temps monsieur gbagbo le fait que les
sociétés d'autoroutes faisait des des
travaux très bien et je reconnais là je
de jeu
d'un satisfecit aux sociétés de toad que
notre réseau autoroutier est très bien
entretenu mais à quel prix et je trouve
que ce qu'on a fait en 2015 avec un
programme de travaux qui a soi disant
coûté 3 milliards de l'autorité de la
concurrence a dit que c'était pas
l'autorité de la concurrence autorités
des transports a dit que c'était plutôt
600 millions de moins mais peu importe
on n'est plus à quelques centaines de
millions 3 milliards et la prorogation
des concessions sager 15 milliards de
plus pour les sociétés d'autoroutes donc
elles ont mis 3 milliards soit en tout -
et en plus pour des travaux effectués
par leurs filiales et en contrepartie ça
leur rapporte 15 milliards ça montre
bien que malheureusement l'état a failli
et que l'état est très mauvais mais en
ces négociations avec les sociétés
d'auto escape ce sont je sais pas lequel
d'entre vous peut répondre mais ce qu
elles ce sont paul kaiser du bien déjà
remboursé les sociétés d'autoroute c'est
à dire que ce qu'elles ont dû payer une
simple est-ce que
votre chronique comme chroniqueur ils se
sont sans doute déjà très largement
remboursé le député ancien député
jean-paul chanteuse grecque a été député
socialiste 2006 à 2017 et qui a présidé
une commission d' enquête sur les
autoroutes qui a rendu un rapport en
deux temps en 2014 indique que de 2006 à
2010 est ce sont 27 milliards d'euros de
dividendes qui ont été versés aux
actionnaires des sociétés le taux de
dividende de profits donc là on est
quand on sait que les autoroutes ont été
acheté pour 14 8 milliards en 2006 on
est au delà du raisonnable donc ça c'est
un argument j'imagine parce que je
reviens à la thématique de la
nationalisation idées neuves ou idées
courtes ça ça peut être un argument pour
renégocier la concession non réellement
y mettre fin après vous bien évidemment
pour y mettre fin de toute urgence il ay
ay si un déséquilibre manifeste des
concessions autoroutières au profit des
personnes privées pour la raison qu'il
n' être indiquée par monsieur le
sénateur qu'effectivement on y à une
inversion des valeurs en ce sens que la
puissance publique est soumise à des
intérêts privés ce qui est complètement
anormal il faut quand même avoir
l'esprit que l'actuel ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire était le
directeur de cabinet 2 munich de
villepin qui a organisé les premières
nations en 2006 et c'est lui aujourd'hui
qui indique qu'il faudrait 44 milliards
d'euros d'indemnisations pour
nationaliser les autoroutes et on va
justement écouter tient bruno le maire
qui répondait à leurs choix c'était
juste après que marine le pen et est
proposé et mis cette idée fait cette
promesse électorale il lui conseille à
la patience
moi j'entends la proposition de marine
le pen en quoi est-ce que nationaliser
des autoroutes va améliorer la situation
de chaque français de vous de moi de
ceux qui nous écoutent ces 40 milliards
d'euros qui vont être dépensés alors que
si on attend 10 ou 15 ans que ce sont
des concessions je le rappelle à madame
le pen on peut récupérer ces autoroutes
pour zéro euro donc il faut juste savoir
nous sommes en septembre 2021 ou est ce
que l'argent des français parce que
c'est l'argent des français sera le
mieux gens prient effectivement on peut
on peut regarder tient une carte qui
montre les différentes concessions elle
est
les dates de fin des contrats qui ont
été signés le premier contrat renégocié
normalement c'est dans dix ans et pour
les autoroutes du sud est et puis ça va
jusqu'en 2036 notamment pour pour celle
du sud ouest et la fameuse a dit ce que
je connais bien un mot laetitia et
ensuite je redonne la parole d'alibaba
moi je trouve que cette argumentation et
ses réponses données par le gouvernement
sont un peu courtes c'est à dire que la
position de
djebbari la position de lemaire comme ça
qui est qui jean baptiste du réseau le
maire donnant les noms et là ça ne m'est
plus prénom jean baptiste djebbar et
bruno le maire qui balaye d'un revers de
main cette proposition à distance et
populiste c'est faux il ya une opacité à
sur le patrimoine jean baptiste djebbari
lui même a dit qu'effectivement on
n'avait pas évalué ce patrimoine afin
c'est complètement fou et ses 40
milliards qui sont avancés par bruno le
maire vienne d'une seule expertise faire
par l'assemblée nationale dans 2014 il
n'y a pas eu d'autres études une
contre-expertise donc c'est très court
alors olivier babeau est-ce que
effectivement on peut évaluer ce que
coûterait la nationalisation des 18
sociétés d'autoroutes j'imagine que si
on met une équipe de juristes
économistes sur le court or à ce jour
les éléments et le contraire je dors on
doit pouvoir y arriver moi je suis assez
étonné du caractère très
décide des sidéens de des déclarations
du gouvernement ils sont très très très
très clairs là dessus et je me dis si
est vraiment de l'argent à se faire s'il
est vraiment quelque chose de possible à
moindre coût pour quoi ils pourquoi il
ne dirait pas pourquoi il ne le ferait
pas pourquoi une autre voie pour quelle
raison sauf à imaginer de conflit
d'intérêts obscurs que je ne voudrais
pas imaginer mais pourquoi pourquoi il
serait si catégorique moi j'ai
l'impression que si bruno le maire dit
que ça coûte dans les 40 milliards c'est
que il doit avoir des éléments faux a
besoin d'eux
wright un contrat d'évaluation
je suis pas professeur de droit mais ce
qui est certain c'est que en réalité dix
ans pour l'état c'est court attendre dix
ans c'est pas la mort et l'idée est de
pouvoir dire on va être meilleur la
prochaine fois ça me paraît déjà une
politique d intéressant après avoir avec
des spécialistes si vraiment ça coûte ça
j'en sais rien je crois pas que qu'on
puisse dire il en attend 10 ans il faut
préparer la zone a dit qu'on serait trop
tarder à arriver disant est ce que ce
que je crains c'est qu'on dise on attend
10 ans ils passaient chose est sûre on
arrive à l'échéance rien n'est préparé
et puis on proche de même on n'a pas
évoqué un point mais qui est important
et qu'il y à tout ça c'est qu'il y à une
demande des sociétés d'autoroute non
seulement de prorogation dans le temps
mais de prorogation ou d'élargissement
de leur périmètre puisque ils ont réussi
à ce qu'on introduit je crois que c'est
dans la l'homme la possibilité de leur
concéder la gestion de certaines routes
nationales et donc là dessus il faut
être très vigilant pour que tout d'un
coup au détour d'un article ou de je ne
sais quoi on veut on passe passe qui est
maintenant malheureusement possible dans
la loi de la concession de route
nationale à ces sociétés d'autoroutes
donc moi je crois que ce qu'il faudrait
c'est mettre tout le monde autour de la
table dès maintenant en disant beau
concessions se termine 2031 milles 32
selon les cas on n'est pas aussi là
l'idée de les proroger n'est pas comme
ça et on négocie tout de suite peut-être
même pour que les règles changent avancé
et sciences ont négocié pour avoir une
situation plus équilibrée donc vous êtes
pour une voix on va dire médiane
centriste c'est bien construit
paul cassia vous êtes un peu plus
radicale dans la dent dans la stratégie
vous vous dites il faudra en sortir tout
de suite mais il ya un contrat c est
pourtant je suis centriste aussi alors
ce qui va se passer comme comme on ne va
rien faire pendant les dix quinze
prochaines années ce qui va se passer
très concrètement c'est que les
actionnaires des sociétés d'autoroutes
va empocher 40 milliards 50 milliards de
dividendes au cours des prochaines
années et ses 40 et 50 mineurs auraient
pu aller dans la poche du contribuable
c'est sale c'est ça le non choix actuel
revient à ce résultat un contrat de
concession peut se casser alors je suis
devant ça et ça mc tout moment c'est
prévu dans les contrats c'est dans les
articles 38 à tout moment pour une
raison d'intérêt général donc ça c'est
ça c'est ça c'est écrit noir sur blanc
une raison d'intérêts comment ça peut
tenir bien évidemment mais
c'est la loi des contrats c'est la
jurisprudence classique du conseil
d'état que l'administration peut mettre
fin à tout moment un contrat de
concession à condition d'indemniser le
concessionnaire mais cette indemnisation
elle n'est due que si le concessionnaire
a subi un manque à gagner or vous nous
disiez que ils ont largement remboursé
le justement de toute évidence il est
manifeste que les concessionnaires n'ont
aucun manque à gagner je reprend
l'argument de olivier babeau pourquoi le
gouvernement ne le fait pas non je n'ai
6 à 6,6 ça ne coûte rien ou pas grand
chose je les ignore pourquoi le
gouvernement ne fait pas je constate
simplement qu'on a le je le répète le
ministre de l'économie actuelle et l
ancien directeur de cabinet de dominique
de villepin donc il a peut-être une
appétence particulière pour la
privatisation ou imola aux errances
politique en tout cas oui oui qu un
aveuglement identique au cours des
années je ne sais pas ce n'est pas que
cette unité politique tout de même
puisque ségolène royal avait tenté quand
elle était ministre de l'écologie de
faire en tout cas imposé la gratuité
tout en le week-end et de faire baisser
les tarifs manuel valls
oui
rien avoir envoyé non mais même manuel
valls dire que même à notre sensibilité
politique il y avait un attentisme sur
cette question le gel des prix des
péages a coûté très cher ou souvent à
l'usagé puisque non seulement ça a été
rattrapé mais avec des majorations donc
ce coup politique de ségolène royal a
coûté très cher à l'usagé donc c'est
bien de donner des coups de menton mais
après il faut assumer alors justement je
reviens à la question est-ce qu'une
nationalisation ça ça serait forcément
favorable aux usagers est ce que est ce
qu'on aurait une meilleure autoroute ne
gérez et qui coûte forcément moins cher
moi j'en suis pas j'en suis pas
convaincu je suis convaincu qu'il faut
revoir les équilibres oui parce que
mettons qu'on nationalise à quel prix si
si on était sûr de ce que dit arnaud
montebourg que ça coûterait que 300000
euros je dirais votre est bien allons-y
vraiment mais personne personne ne peut
dire ce que la justice détermine ray
comme juste prix on avait que les avec
une évaluation judiciaire dans quelques
domaines que ce soit on sait jamais où
on arrive ensuite une fois qu'on a fait
ça qu'est-ce qu'on en fait des
autoroutes comme on les gère on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui les services de
l'état qui n'ont fait que se paupériser
sont incapables du jour au lendemain de
reprendre en charge l'entretien des
autoroutes y'a qu'a voir et encore une
fois je suis pas un défenseur des
sociétés d'autoroutes mais y'a qu'à voir
les parties du réseau autoroutier qui ne
sont pas concédé on voit tout de suite
quand on sort de la partie concédé et
qu'on arrive dans une partie qui ne
l'est pas vous arrivez dans certaines
zones en ile-de-france les les panneaux
sont illisibles tellement ils ont ils
sont mal entretenues ou pas changé bon
donc on ne peut pas non plus du jour au
lendemain dire c'est fini les
concessions ou quoi je crois que la
procession dans l'état actuel des choses
c'est pas une mauvaise chose mais encore
une fois il faudrait essayer d'entamer
dès à présent un bras de fer en disant
si vous voulez avoir une petite chance
qu'on proche encore les contrats de
concession à partir de 2031 on revoit
les choses pour la suite on revoit les
choses quand quant à votre rémunération
on revoit les choses quand on contrôle
voilà
musclé dix ans d'un ego non mais
justement on dira si vous voulez qu'en
2031 tout ne s'arrête pas dès à présent
on revoit les choses c'est ça ce que je
propose dès à présent on revoit les
choses sans attente 2031 et si vous ne
voulez pas c'est effectivement votre
droit mais vous pouvez être certains
déjà présente en 2031 ce sera fini voilà
je reviens quand même là la question des
usagers de ce que ça changerait pour
nous utilisateurs des autoroutes olivier
babeau est ce que l'état ferait aussi
bien que le privé pour entretenir les
autoroutes on peut effectivement leur
donner un satisfecit de d'entretien
aujourd'hui oui on a vraiment on va tout
le monde s'accorde pour dire qu'on a les
autoroutes vraiment de meilleure qualité
d'europe1 probablement alors avec un
prix qui effectivement celui ci le
supplie qu'on connaît la philosophie de
la concession c'est deux choses s'est
d'abord développé un réseau utile
collectivement sans bourse délier pour
l'état pour des raisons x ou y ils ont
pas envie de le faire eux-mêmes et la
deuxième chose c'est imaginer que un
opérateur spécialiste peut faire les
choses à moindre coût collectif
théoriquement si les choses sont bien
sont bien déterminés que ne le ferait
l'état assure que l'état ça va être
aussi des personnes de fonctionnaires
qui vont être payés par la collectivité
donc il faut il faut voir la vision
d'ensemble et savoir c'est un peu une un
choix un arbitrage prix qualité si vous
voulez hein alors peut-être qu'on
pourrait baisser le prix mais est ce
qu'on est prêt à y perdre beaucoup de
qualités ou est ce que finalement on
n'aurait pas d'ailleurs des utilités du
gâchis et qui ferait qu' on aurait des
mois les autoroutes qui continuera à
être géré collectivement et là on aurait
complètement perdus c'est pour ça qu'il
faut effectivement bien réfléchir ce qui
implique beaucoup de transparence de
connaissances sur les sur les flux sur
ce qui s'est passé
sur ce que ça sur ce que ça implique et
d'anticipation parce qu'il faut pas
oublier pascal est dans un domaine hyper
technologique pas qui de plus en plus
technologique qui connaît une triple
révolution on va dire demain ça sera des
voitures autonome oui on veut dire des
technologies seulement de la salle que
vous êtes c'est beaucoup plus
technologique que ça et donc est ce
qu'on a une vision de ce que sera la
route dans 20 ans et de ce que ça doit
faire en plus en partenariat avec toutes
les autres mobilité parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous savez c'est évidemment la
complémentarité des mobilités évidemment
derrière il ya tout l'aménagement du
territoire donc c'est un problème qui
est pas seulement un problème de gros
sauts ou de ou de petits sous d'ailleurs
pour monsieur madame tout le monde c'est
un problème d'aménagement du territoire
développement économique beaucoup plus
large donc ça veut dire qu'il faut le
penser dans le cadre de ces politiques
là ce qu'on appelle la multi modalité
vrai quand même terminé sa visite c'est
passionnant sur sur la question de
l'opacité et du contrôle qui contrôle
par exemple pour les ponts les ouvrages
d'art hervé morin qui contrôle les
sociétés d'autoroutes alors l'opacité je
crois que l'extrait qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure montre bien cette opacité que
j'avais rappelé qu'on n'avait jamais pu
avoir l'accord signé entre l'état les
sociétés d'autoroutes justement dans en
2015 quand il eut ce plan de relance et
vous avez vu ce qu'on m'a répondu on va
dire il ya aussi de médiapart donc je
crois que les extrêmes où est passé
sur le rôle des ponts sujet
effectivement sur lequel on a on a aussi
travaillé bon encore une fois je crois
qu'on a un réseau qui est plutôt bien
entretenu mais ce qui n'est pas
satisfaisant c'est que sur les dans le
domaine autoroutier ce sont les sociétés
elles mêmes qui contrôlent leurs
ouvrages et ensuite éventuellement les
services de l'état qui contrôle le
contrôle mais voyez bien que les
sociétés d'autoroutes cc c'est vraiment
elle qui domine l'état et pas l'inversé
c'est ça qu'il faut totalement aux
joueurs paul cassia
willow facilité ou même le
malheureusement l'opacité est entretenu
par l'état lui-même puisque en 2015
l'état n'a pas voulu communiquer
l'accord signé par emmanuel macron et
ségolène royal donc effectivement le
sénateur avait demandé cet accord
sociétés d'autoroutes mais en premier
lieu il aurait dû être communiquée par
par l'état lui-même donc et l'état
entretient cette opacité est la
meilleure preuve en est qu'on ne sait
toujours pas aujourd'hui quel est le
montant exact d'une indemnisation
éventuelle en cas de cessation anticipée
des concessions la transparence aurait
voulu que les fonctionnaires
l'inspection générale des finances soit
mandaté pour travailler sur ce point là
pour que nous débattions sur des bases
objectif ce n'est jamais fait donc on
est dans l'opacité la plus totale et qui
est entretenue par l'état lui-même ce
qui est très regrettable merci beaucoup
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat il a filé
rapidement ce qui est toujours très bon
signe c'était très intéressant je vous
donne rendez vous évidemment demain pour
un nouveau sens public